okay so in this short video we're gonna
compare and contrast convergent
evolution to divergent evolution so
let's go ahead and get started well
let's start by focusing on divergent
evolution the evolution of two or more
species from a common ancestor you know
kind of the classic example that you're
often gonna run across it is the Darwin
finches you may know that Charles Darwin
set upon a journey where he explored the
Galapagos Islands and on the Galapagos
Islands were many species of finches and
so the Darwin Finch is a great example
of divergent evolution how did there
become so many species of these finches
well it is believed that if we look at
the the map here and on mainland South
America lived the ancestral species of
today's Darwin finches and over time
some happened to migrate over towards
the Galapagos Islands the small grouping
of islands off the western coast of
Ecuador if we zoom on in when we zoom on
in here we see the the the original
finches that migrated here from the
coast of South America and as time
passed finches would multiply they would
reproduce with one another and multiply
and they would adapt to their
surroundings so they multiply but then
some of them of course might venture out
and explore and migrate to other islands
which have slightly different conditions
than the island they just came from so
they over time begin to adapt to these
this new island and multiply and as time
goes by they begin to again migrate
outward and they come to a third island
which has slightly different conditions
than the other islands and as time
passes they reproduce and multiply and
they adapt to the conditions of this
island and then as time passes some
begin to migrate outward and they come
to yet another island on the Galapagos
that has slightly different features
than all the others
so they adapt they multiply that type
they diversify and eventually the
process continues where again some may
migrate to another yet another island
with its own unique environment and they
begin to adapt and multiply and and
basically take on the characteristics
best able to survive in this particular
environment and today there's actually
13 different species of Darwin finches
but you can see why it's called
divergent evolution I hope these 13 have
diverged from the one common ancestor
that used to live on a mainland of South
America so here's a kind of another
example here of divergent evolution
closer to home here in for those of us
who are in the United States watching
this video you know the Grand Canyon
today is just this magnificent
geographic feature in the American
Southwest well but it wasn't always that
way
so there are these squirrels that live
in the Grand Canyon's and you know right
now let's go back in time and right now
we can see the squirrels I have gene
flow they're able to migrate between the
northern and southern areas of this of
this ecosystem here but as time passes
and the Grand Canyon forms so as time
passes and the Grand Canyon becomes what
it is today
notice how the two populations of
squirrels are no longer able to
reproduce with one another there's no
gene flow the two groups have become
isolated from one another and this has
led to the divergence of the ancestral
species today there are the Kaibab
squirrels of the northern rim and the a
brute squirrels of the southern rim but
because they've diverged from one common
ancestor I think it's a really nice
visual example of divergent evolution
and so really the pattern that we see is
that species will adapt to the
environment where they live through the
acts of natural selection organisms that
are best suited for let let's say the
Noir
rym are more likely to survive and
reproduce but that's probably gonna be a
little different than the organisms best
suited for the southern rim who are
gonna survive and reproduce a little
differently okay then so what is
convergent evolution well this is when
unrelated species will independently
evolved similar traits well why why
would unrelated species independently
evolved similar traits well we noticed
that is that when we see examples of
this they tend to share a similar
environment or a similar ecological
niche you know a real nice visual
example of this comes in in ocean
organisms like the tuna example tuna is
a type of fish and dolphins which
although look very fish like in their
appearance and dolphins I'm sure you may
know are mammals and yet and then
there's also penguins penguins birds and
yet they too have some very fish-like
features to them so notice how the
bodies of these animals very different
organisms here the tuna the mammal the
tuna which is a fish that dolphin which
is a man when the penguin which is a
bird unrelated species to one another
and yet they've evolved similar
characteristics well what do they have
in common well they they live in the
similar a similar environment they live
in the oceans and whether you're a fish
or a mammal or a bird if you live and
survive in the ocean then there are
certain traits that will lead your
survival having a smooth body and
streamlined body with fins and flippers
to help propel yourself through the
water these are advantages that you're
gonna pass along to your offspring over
time and whether you're a fish whether
you're even ma'am or whether you're a
bird these are traits that become more
common over time another example would
be in this example here flying squirrels
which actually are rodents and sugar
gliders which are marsupials marsupials
you may know are related to animals like
kangaroos so flying squirrels being
rodents sugar gliders being marsupials
are not really related at all and yet
when you examine them they look very
similar to one another to have these
skin flaps in between the front legs and
their hind legs which allows them to
kind of glide short distances as they're
jumping through trees so they share a
common environment you know being that
they're tree living organisms and so
they've adapted to that similar
environment they've adapted these common
traits and so really the pattern we
learn here is that if different species
live in similar environments that over
time they'll converge they'll become
they will develop common features well
let's kind of wrap this up with a little
conclusion here again divergent
evolution the evolution of two or more
species from a common ancestor you know
this drawing right here I totally
believe it's pronounced yo hippest is
believed to be the common ancestor of
organisms like donkeys and zebras and
horses but again a great example of
divergence evolution because donkeys and
horses and zebras have diverged to
become different species originating
from this one common ancestor here and
yet we can contrast that with convergent
evolution which again is the is when
unrelated species independently evolved
similar traits kind of another
interesting example of convergent
evolution is when we look at eagles
which is a type of bird and bats which
are a type of mammal and you know a
butterfly which is a type of insect
these are very unrelated species again
birds and mammals and insects they're
not related and yet they've converged on
their ability to fly they've taken
advantage of the common environment
where they live and that would be like
the air so again I hope you found this
video helpful too short a short video to
compare and contrast divergent versus
convergent evolution thanks for watching